an explosive error here on Sky News with
our political editor Beth Rigby and of
course the three candidates vying to
replace Nicholas sturgeon at the top of
the SNP and of course replacing her as
Scotland's first Minister let's get some
instant reaction from four people here
in at the studio with us we've got Billy
Lee Rob uh who is representing the ash
Regan campaign Michelle Thompson from
the kit Forbes Camp uh Neil Gray from
Hamza yusuf's team and an impartial
voice Nicola uh Professor Nicola McKeon
from the University of Edinburgh
um Professor McCune first of all to you
who won
oh I'm not going to judge that what I
would say is that you mentioned
explosive and I think it was a lot more
explosive than I had thought it would be
after the softer version softer tone to
the the previous leaders debate
um and that's a real challenge a real
problem for the SNP in a sense because
it gives the impression of a party that
is divided and voters generally don't
like divided parties it's entirely
appropriate that choosing a new leader
it leads to a robust exchange over the
direction of travel for the party
appropriate for the voters the public to
see that since it's their first Minister
too but whoever emerges from this as the
winner will have a massive job on their
hands to rewrite the part Neil gray was
that not a mud-slinging match that the s
p has been trying to avoid over the
course of the last couple of weeks so I
think it was a robust exchange of views
and I think we're all United on the
panel and in this leadership contest
around the desire the need for Scottish
Independence I think what divides us is
the the route by which we get there and
the vision for our government going
forward Hamza set out a very compelling
and strong case for why it's important
that we maintain that Progressive
platform that has taken us to
unprecedented levels of support under
Nicholas sturgeon eight election wins in
a row in eight years hums is looking to
maintain that and build upon it in order
to build a team that can take us over
the Tipping Point for Independence
Michelle Thompson that was not a display
of party Unity at all was it well it
wasn't meant to be a display of party
unit Unity what it was meant to be for
each of the candidates to put their
credentials front and center and set out
how exactly they would lead the SNP
going forward and in that respect having
looked at social media after the debate
until now it's utterly clear
that keep Forbes one that hands down
Billy Lee that uh I'm assuming is
something you would not agree with but
you're a candidate in this race was uh
the the economic policy was drilled down
and exposed big holes didn't it in Nash
Regan's plans well uh I mean coming in
there I I I thank both candidates had a
great performance but I think actually
again one hands down clearly Ash is the
only one that has put forward a plan for
Independence and you've saved the other
economic force was put put to test it
absolutely that is what this whole the
institutions that would be required to
set up that Central Bank well she did
she had named a few institutions
I I write there with Beth rugby but what
is fundamental and what Michigan and
other candidates have said throughout
this whole process is that the shortened
election period prevents candidates from
putting forward a field policy platform
so where else we would love to outline
all our policies in depth in detail
fully costage fully plan we're unable to
do so because of the short election
Michelle Thompson the reality is here is
it not that this is a two-horse race and
you need to get Ash Regan's votes on
side in order to win this don't you we
don't need to I believe Kate will win I
think she's utterly the strongest
candidate the areas where she's doing
really well if we look at the polls
which I know Professor McCune is an
expert in but all the polls show us that
with the general public in terms of net
favorability ratings she is ahead of the
pack she's ahead of the pack because she
understands about the need for change
her statement continuity won't cut it is
really cutting through she understands
about the economics and the finance that
means that she can properly start to
address the cost of living crisis so she
I believe is going to win and Neil gray
that's the problem isn't it there's
Panic within your team that Cape Forbes
could win this that's the reality no
there's not uh we have set out a very
measured campaign we've had a very
successful campaign the poll that you've
published today demonstrates that that
Hamza Yusuf is ahead quite substantially
ahead amongst SMP voters both those that
voted in 2019 and those that are about
would wish to uh in the next Hollywood
election so Hamza has gone from a
position of being behind Cape Forbes
amongst SMP voters and in the general
public he's a double he's quadruple to
support amongst the general public and
he is substantially ahead regardless of
which measure you use for SMP support he
is now 19 points ahead in one and 14
points ahead in the other uh Professor
McCune it was interesting wasn't to to
hear the candidates pivoting to
essentially two different audiences did
you get the sense that Hamza Yusuf was
speaking directly to SMP voters whereas
Cape Forbes was was looking at the
broader church here and trying to appeal
and take advantage of what the polls are
saying that she appeals to that broader
audience
I think they're probably doing both of
those things but also playing to their
strengths but the reality is that the
public don't decide this leadership
election s p voters don't even decide
this leadership election it's the
members that matter and what we don't
know is well we know that the SMP has a
very large membership we don't know how
many of them will participate in this
election we have a little bit of an
inkling as to the values and attitudes
of of the SMP membership from a survey a
few years ago
um but and that would suggest that they
would perhaps lean more towards towards
Hamza but we don't know
um how much they will value the the
attitudes the the social issues the
conservative issues as opposed to the
competence issues who do they believe
were the most competence to lead to the
SMP Michelle Thompson you issued a
fairly explosive to use that phrase
again a statement over the weekend when
there was that intervention by the
deputy first Minister John Sweeney to
back Neil Gray's candidate in the race
here Hamza Yusuf do you believe that
this contest is rigged in favor of Hamza
Yusuf from party HQ I I absolutely don't
believe it is rigged in favor I was
merely commenting the fact that I
personally believe it's not appropriate
for the deputy first minister to seek to
use his influence to try and persuade
people to vote why not he's a member
he's a member like everyone else because
he holds a position of great power and I
thought he should have taken exactly the
same view and the entirely appropriate
position of the first Minister as a
deputy first Minister it's inappropriate
absolutely not John has got one vote the
same way as everybody else does in the
party but he obviously also has great
standing within the party John has
dedicated 40 years of service to the SNP
and to the people of Scotland his
judgment is absolutely well respected
across the party because of that length
of service and he's been able to see a
close hand the three candidates that are
put before us in this election he has
decided that his up values and his
judgment aligns closest to Hamza Yusuf
and that's why he's given him his
endorsement it is a ringing endorsement
and one I absolutely celebrate but is it
fair to say that party HQ wants hanza to
win I have no idea what part of HQ wants
to do we've got no involvement from
party headquarters they're here merely
to administrate the the process not to
get involved in the campaign and anyone
suggesting otherwise is playing in
conspiracy theories
um Bailey Lee the reality here is that
Ash Regan is not going to win this is
she well I wouldn't agree with that
statement at all I mean I think Ash has
is the only one that can gain from this
I mean you you we're speaking polls Ash
started the way down I think at four
percent but now up at 14 15 the the
polls are showing that Asheville only
continue to go upwards so Ash is the one
here that has everything to gain and I
absolutely believe that she has the
potential to win this and become
Scotland is like first Mercer and what a
great first Master she would be and it
would be the last first semester that
we'd have under this Devolution
settlement Neil gray is Ash credible
set out her campaign as she's seen fit
she's obviously picking up uh support
from it but I firmly believe that Hamza
Yusuf is the candidate that will ensure
that we maintain our Progressive
platform that we maintain the popular
support that we have earned and
re-earned under the stewardship is Ash
Regan credible well I think she has a
credible platform that she's seeking to
put forward but I believe that the most
credible platform is the one that's been
put forward by Hamza Yusuf that will
ensure that we do not lose the popular
support that we have earned we've got to
re-earn that trust of the people of
Scotland not just for the SNP but for
the cause of Independence and I believe
Hamza Yusuf is the best set to ensure
that he can persuade uh the people of
Scotland to take us beyond the point of
Independence no well the polls show well
sure that amongst independent we're
almost Running Out of Time dependent
support we've said that comes in front
we've heard that during the debate
nickel McKeon how does whoever wins this
contest
unite a party
um it was very difficult
um but I think that the SMP has proven
itself over the last number of years to
be a formidable electoral machine and it
will have to try to ensure that that all
kicks into gear again because there's
not very much time before the next big
electoral test of of the general
election and now if uh Kate does emerge
as the the winning candidate then she
has the additional challenge of not
really being supported by most of the
senior figures within the SNP within the
Scottish government so that's an
additional challenge for her
um but whoever emerges it will have to
try to unite
um again just a final thought on
Michelle Thompson that's the reality uh
Kate Forbes has alienated in this race
and who would serve in in her cabinet
absolutely not you have to
have done and this is a com IC option
people are setting out their souls I am
absolutely confident that when Kate wins
people will be clambering to serve in
her government and take Scotland the
next stage in its journey to
Independence would you serve in a cape
Forbes cabinet Neil gray I'll always be
looking to ensure I serve the people on
the credible mandate that has been given
to us to the people of Scotland which is
a progressive agenda and I'll be seeking
to ensure that Hamza Yusuf is the first
Minister that can maintain that
Progressive mandate that can ensure we
not just win the next election but win
our independence and regardless of who's
first Minister though I believe it will
be Hamza of course I'd have a
conversation about how we make sure we
have a progressive mandate delivered to
the people of Scotland Bailey Lee final
thought from you what do you make of
what you've heard from everyone else I I
think it's funny because what has been
set out there is that accordingly that
Hamza is the only one that will continue
their SMP another Progressive Party
ludicrous the party is Progressive the
party itself is Progressive not just one
individual it's not to say that just
because Nicholas sturgeon is leaving
that the progressiveness goes if Hamza
doesn't win each candidate has set out
their store I believe that ashigan has
said the best though Ash is going to be
the one that continues that Progressive
vision for Scotland Ash will take us to
that Independence
I'm clear on that okay Bailey Lee uh Rob
from the ashigan camp Michelle Thompson
from Cape Forbes uh Neil Gray from Hamza
Yusuf and Professor Nicola McHugh thanks
very much for your time on Sky News and
that is it from the outskirts of
Edinburgh this evening lots to mull over
as this contest continues for another
few weeks uh when the winner will
eventually be crowned on the 27th of
March